all right when the Music Stops please
find a
seat good
morning opening the executive session on
House Bill 1013 representative D Simone
relative to amending the definition of
temporary alimony and and I believe you
have an amendment or somebody has an
amendment on 1013 not at this time Mr
chair well this is the time this we do
not have an amendment okay so would you
like to make a
motion
motion would you like to turn on your
microphone now you like to make a motion
wow you get me all coordinated Mr
chairman thank you oh my mother could
hear that
maybe she does and you just don't
know
um I would like to make a motion of
octop pass
on um House Bill 1013
please and okay that's a good start I
like it when we start that way and would
you speak
to um what we're going to vote
on um as soon as I find
it
um I think that it's very important for
us to realize that um in a a
very difficult situation such
as and I cannot find the bill I
apologize do you have it and an
annotated copy no less look at that huh
that really great he see he runs the
city of Manchester he does so he does
yeah thank you
Lord but I I just believe that uh
temporary alimony is a necessity for
both men and
women um who
are unfortunately facing
divorce and one or the other is left
with little or no income so a temporary
alimony situation I think works really
well
uh and this bill will speak to that
and uh give those people who would
otherwise suffer Financial
travesties uh something to go
on so I would appreciate the support of
the
committee anyone
else representative
Bickford thank you Mr chairman um as I
recall we've had temporary Al want for
some time what this bill does I believe
is direct you to direct the uh Court to
utilize the formula which I'm not that
familiar with it came in during during
my two times here yeah could you can you
explain a little bit about the uh
formula I'm not very well versed on the
formula however the reason that uh we
wanted to uh get involved with the
formula is because it creates
consistency in the court it gives uh the
the court the opportunity to say to
all uh people who come before them this
is the this is the formula this is what
we're allowed to give you this is what
we'll
do okay thank you I recall attorney
marel uh used the word
predictability
correct anyone
else
that your sub yeah okay just you know
when we sent out for a sub I wanted a
Diet Coke with it yeah my C why ice
coffee well they weren very good atation
I needed so Mr Sullivan is it yes yes
welcome welcome thanks any further
questions on or testimony on 10:13
anything anybody else wants to say
then it has been moved by representative
D Simon and seconded by representative
long the bill is 1013 the motion is
ought to pass with the clerk please call
the role chairman Pearson yes
representative La yes representative
disimon yes representative bfid yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball is not
here at the moment representative P
Panic yes representative
Sidell yes representative Jared Sullivan
yes representative LC is not is here I
see you yes okay representative Patrina
will be voting yes representative Perez
is absent representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons is absent
representative Raymond yes motion
carries
14 13 to three
13-3 the motion 13 to Z to Z excuse me I
13 to zero yeah 13 to zero with three
absent I only had one cup of coffee this
morning and I
apologize three options it's a strange
day when the chair corrects the clerk on
a detail oh dear cherish this I am and
representative D simoney you will be
writing the committee report
I I shall Mr chairman thank you and it's
due
today all
right this uh ends the um exec session
on House Bill 1013 and I open the exact
session now on 12:16 9 which is about
restraints and all of that and
um
1269 I'm going in disorder because of
people who are here okay but thank you
thank you that's all right
um and um I'd like to start with a
positive motion on this um so I guess
that means I'll have to make it uh the
chair moves ought to pass do I have a
second representative Panic
seconds discussion we have some people
here we have someone from the Department
of
Education uh to bring a brief
clarification we are not re hearing the
bill we're not so much taking testimony
but since this um became more and more
complicated as the days marched on uh
there may need to be a little bit of
clarification so if I could call the
person from doe up
please
you get Five Points by the way a lot of
people don't do that turn on the mic
uned well I wrote it on my hand today so
I I kind of you belong in education I I
do I really do I appreciate that thank
you good morning um for the record my
name is Diana Fenton I'm an attorney
with the Department of Education um I'm
just here to answer any questions this
committee might have um in regards to
technical assistance my understanding
was that when this bill was heard I was
not present and there was some
information provided about what was
available on the department's website
and I really just wanted to clarify
what's on our website that first and
foremost we are in compliance with the
restraint and seclusion laws that were
passed last session um what the
department has on its website currently
are two technical advisories that were
issued in response to the legislative
changes that were made last session the
first one was made just based on the two
bills bills that were passed the Senate
bill and the corresponding House Bill
the second technical advisory was issued
based upon questions that we were
receiving from the field some points of
clarification as to the interpretation
of the new laws um and then most
recently in working with the Department
of Health and Human Services as we were
required to do by law we have issued the
restraint and seclusion form that is a
fillable PDF that is available on our
website and we have sent that out to the
field and as I always say um nothing
that I ever produce will be perfect I
wish I could say it would be but we are
open to suggestions and feedback from
the field it is really a working
document so we're getting feedback and
and trying to address any of concerns
that that we're hearing um so I just
wanted to clarify that for this
committee I'm happy to answer any
questions and thank you for any
questions for tney Fenton of clarifying
nature representative long you have a
tell you know I know when you're going
to want a question you have a tell I'll
explain it later thank you Mr chairman
uh and thank you for the opportunity uh
one of the concerns is uh prior to the
use uh of constraints
uh immediately after seclusion
or
uh
as soon as on line 32 22 actually as
soon as
practical um my my issue is with
other
children uh in the classroom and and
being
identified um is that's somewhat of a
worry to uh
goe I think the short answer is is yes
um in terms of the video being released
that's the bigger concern um we deal
with those concerns on a somewhat
regular basis if you recognize that
there are a lot of uh recording devices
in hallways not NE not in classrooms but
in the hallways that if there is an
incident at a school in a hallway then
there presumably would be other children
uh videotaped and so what the schools
will typically do and I can't speak for
every school obviously but typically
they will blur other children's faces or
make it so that the only focus is on the
particular child or the particular
incident whatever the situation might be
so there are ways to address that
concern um I also think that if you
think about when restraint and seclusion
occur restraint and seclusion and and I
by no means am an expert I am a lawyer
I'm not from the field I'll be always
the first one to to acknowledge that but
I have become somewhat of an expert in
just working with the field on this very
complicated topic and what the field
will tell you and I think it's so
important for this committee to hear
from the field on this topic in
particular it's a challenging area for
educators it really is some of the
behaviors they are seeing are very very
complex and and challenging um this is
not a tool that they like to use it's
not a tool that they use on the regular
basis but it is a tool to control
dangerous escalating
behavior and typically it is used once
the child has already been removed they
utilize therapeutic intervention and the
statute speaks to that it doesn't Define
that term but it speaks to therapeutic
intervention um and
so could other children be caught on
camera if when videotaping it yes they
could could that's the reality of it but
typically the child has already been
removed to a different area a separate
area not necessarily secluded but
removed from that that area where the
issue is already occurring so I think it
is a smaller likelihood than having
cameras in the hallway but again my
caveat to my testimony is that the
people that really know the ins and outs
of restraint and seclusion are the
amazing Educators who have who are
tasked with doing it every
day I get thank you Mr chairman uh we
did hear from uh Mr
Rosenberg um
who uh who stated that it needed work uh
particularly with students with special
needs and IEPs um because it's emergency
only that this will take
effect um and and she was concerned
about even their ident
identity uh you know being out to uh you
know to parents who wish to see the
recording uh well the parents wouldn't
be an issue they already know that uh
but those that wouldn't know um that a
person with special needs or had an
IEP um would you see that
problematic
just to clarify your question are you
talking about identifying a child who
has an IEP or special needs yeah um yes
it could it could be problematic anytime
you release that information document
that information absolutely okay yes one
more for I one more uh I mean it it
appeared to me that this was a marac
issue I get that I I did I'm from
Manchester and I asked my district and
there uh the the testimony we heard uh
my my district didn't have those issues
I know somebody testified that there
were five people standing at an open
seclusion door with the child inside I
know you need you you need to get a
trusted adult for that child whomever
that may be whether it's a coach whether
it's somebody not in the schools so we
heard a testimony that that wasn't
happening um and and that that was part
of this bill um because that wasn't
happening uh which is already in
statute um so I do you see this
widespread throughout the
state and to clarify do I see the need
for this
yes I I can't say that I see the need
for it um my observations and and again
it really is just my
observations this is a challenging area
of the
law um I think school districts and
special education teachers are
struggling to fully comprehend what last
year's legislative changes mean I think
it is important to recognize that this
is used in an emergency
situation these tools and they are tools
restraint and seclusion are tools I
don't know of a single educator who
looks forward to interacting with a
child in this capacity
um they are highly trained individuals
and I know that a lot the schools put a
lot of time and effort and resources
into ensuring that this is done properly
and in accordance with the law and it's
only done in those emergency
situations what I've heard from the
field
is they're struggling they're struggling
with the changes that were made last
year of fully understanding how to
implement them of understanding how this
is information is being utilized um
again um it's it's a challenging area of
the law they want to make sure that they
are giving the child what they need to
make sure that the child is safe and the
people around them are safe and at the
same time they are so self-aware and and
conscientious not to to violate the law
um and so it really is I think a very
delicate balancing act very good thank
you repres resentative
Panic thank you uh Mr chairman for
allowing me to ask a question and thank
you for your for coming in today do you
feel that this will help reduce the
amount of
lawsuits um against the teachers or
maybe
another administrator in the school
system by having the
videos
I'm not aware of of any lawsuits that
are
occurring um I'm sure they are I'm just
not aware of any so I don't know if I'm
in a position to say whether it would
reduce them or or increase them I I
don't know
um I think your question is probably
better targeted
to the educ ators who engage in this
work directly I would hesitate to go any
further in my testimony that I already
have because I'm again I'm not from the
field um and I've never re I've never
engaged in Restraint or seclusion of a
child and so when I train in this area
when I work with the field in this area
I'm always the first to admit my my
deficiencies that this is not an area
that I that I work with the irony is my
mom was a special educator who did do
this work um but I haven't had that
personal
experience um uh I I go back to my prior
testimony this is an area that educators
are very well trained in but it's hard
it's a hard area and you're always
trying to maintain that delicate balance
of of having to react in an emergency
situation and I again use that word for
a purpose it is an emergency situation
to use these tools to calm down a child
who is escalating to the point of
causing harm to themselves or others and
and not wanting their work to be Monday
morning quarterbacked for lack of a
better term or second guest um I think
that's what I'm hearing from the field I
know that doesn't directly answer your
question and I apologize for that I
think it's the best I can
do thank
you representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um attorney Fenton um we got a
number of emails from parents parents
who wanted to know about their rights to
opt out of this kind of surveillance um
so parents who are concerned that um
schools might be you know if if this
passes if they were um videotaping their
students that schools would be using it
to make a case on you know sending kids
out of their their local District or um
or or uh families who felt that um this
might be a scary and uncomfortable thing
for their kids and so my question is
what do we have that protects a parent's
right to opt out because currently we
have opt outs in law for like
photography and other things is there
anything in law that would protect those
parents who don't want their children to
be subjected to this type of
surveillance it's
interesting and while you're looking
that up there would not be such a right
for the video in the hall suddenly to
shut off when that child walks by and
shut back and turn back on when the
child is passed would there be which is
a ridiculous question I know the answer
no I I do really well with ridiculous
questions just so you know so um you
come to the right
place well you're asking the right
lawyer um the answer is no and I'm
certainly not aware of anything like
that the opt out provision that I'm very
familiar with is in
hold on 186 it deals with the surveys
18611 Roman
numeral
9d and that deals with non-academic
surveys being provided to Children um
and there's that opt out provision so
certainly this committee could look at
at that as some potential guidance um
different however AER survey given in a
calm environment
versus videotaping in again an emergency
situation but I think that the language
in the law I did hear some murmuring
after your
question
um it's already in that
IEP plan presumably
um and the parent can agree to that or
not agree to that uh I think it's
important to recognize that even
children who don't have an IP can some
times have restraint and seclusion
applied it's not just limited to a
certain um population so it might not be
addressed in every
instance representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question this is um
actually further to that section okay so
um what I'm reading is as soon as
practicable pursuant to RSA 189 colon 68
blah blah each use of seclusion shall be
visually and auditorally recorded if
such method of recording is included in
the students individualized education
program or accommodation plan my
question is
legally um if this is um part of a
child's IEP it's an emergency situation
therefore there might be an occasion
where videoing
is
not practical or or not happening for
whatever reason would that set the
school district up for a lawsuit
because that
um was not session of restraining um for
lack of better terms sorry um was not
recorded in an emergency situation thank
you for answer my question uh thank you
for the question so you're right if it's
included in the student IEP plan
um could could a family could a parent
or Guardian file a a grievance yes could
they file a lawsuit potentially um
certainly I don't see what the remedy
would be for a violation in the law and
that's certainly something this
committee could take into a
consideration
um but yes the way it's written is as
soon as practicable um each use of
seclusion shall be video visually and
auditorally recorded if included in that
plan
yep representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman thank you um the way I'm
understanding this is there's an IEP and
an accommodation plan in or which I'm
not familiar with what accommodation
plan is by the way but if it's put in
there I assume it's put in by the parent
in the accommodation or
IEP would that be correct so uh thank
you for your question let me answer the
first part the accommodation so the
accommodation is is called a 504
accommodation and a 504 accommodation
can be for a variety of things it can be
um if you need additional time to take a
test it can be if you need um to be in
acquired area to to take a test um I
will share with you on a personal note
my son has scoliosis he has a back brace
and so he has a 504 accommodation plan
that allows him to leave the classroom
early to go to the nurse's office to
take that off whatever the case may be
um it's not an IP it's an accommodation
and you'll find a wide variety of
accommodations going back to the I AP
question the I is created with a team
and the team includes the parent parent
voice Guardian voice is very important
part of that school district um special
education teacher regular education
teacher it is a team of people who
create this
IEP on you know in the best of
circumstances everyone is in agreement
however we have seen at the department
um that sometimes there is there is
disagreement between those team members
as to what is best for that student so
there can be those disagreements there
can be partial consent there can be no
consent to an IP um but in a perfect
situation the IP is agreed to by the
parent and that would of course include
this
language okay so it is voluntary then
follow up yeah yeah voluntary in what
sense uh the that the parents have
agreed to have cameras I mean this what
this is all about having during the
during the uh that would be part of the
I the IEP meeting it wouldn't be written
down in the IEP and the parent would be
able to review that and and then sign
off on it agree to it yes okay and if
they didn't agree to it they don't have
to agree to that portion of it right it
could be signed in what they call
partial consent
yeah okay I think that helps me thank
you you're
welcome thank you thank you very much
for your
time I'd like to call Representative Tim
once again this is not testimony this is
not a hearing but because of any um
needs for clarification I would like to
call the uh Prime sponsor of the bill to
do just that not to re
um redo a hearing but to clarify a few
things that I've heard all kinds of
different answers to the same question
thank you Mr chairman nice to see you
all again appreciate the opportunity to
clarify a few things first let me just
start out by saying that anyone can sue
anyone for any reason I think we know
that parents sue the schools parents Sue
other parents parents sue the
state this bill aims to reduce that in a
tiny fashion or at least make those
types of
claims
obviously correct or incorrect or answer
some of the unanswered questions that we
may see in the
subjective or long or delayed report
writing I mean how many times have you
have people here and in a little fender
bender and the guy says well I had the
right away and you claim you had the
right away and you know you just wish
there was a traffic camera there to
prove exactly what happened because it
would put all of that discussion
immediately to bed it's why we have body
cameras it's why we have surveillance in
schools now it's why the governor and
Council approved $9.8 million
specifically for surveillance and access
control it's why in the city of nashwa
they're going to receive in the city of
Nashville they're going to receive
$170,000 specifically for surveillance
right schools are on board with this
they know it breeds transparency they
know it's for the children for the
students and for the teachers they know
that debunking he said she said is the
easiest way to put a stop to
it representative long
1,434 cases is not an isolated marac
issue that's a Statewide issue and it's
too often and if you think for one
minute it doesn't happen for what cases
of restraint and seclusion reported in
the last full reporting year it was also
from my original testimony but
representative long you commented it's a
marac issue 1,434 cases of restraints
inclusion and seclusion is a Statewide
issue you full disclosure I mentioned
before and so did other testifiers they
mentioned that in some of those cases
it's a multiple multiple uh student you
know a single student with multiple
cases so individual cases is probably
something somewhat less than
1,434 but let's cut it in half let's cut
it in a third let's divide it by five
and it's still too many if you ask me
and there's still too many unanswered
questions and if you think for a second
it doesn't happen in the Manchester
school system ask you to wrap it up now
because it's becoming a rearing of the
testimony agreed so people act
differently when there's a recording
this will protect our most vulnerable
children um we have a lot of privacy
protections that's an issue that come up
several times um we have a lot of
privacy protections we have
uh we have Hippa which doesn't generally
apply here because it's a health health
uh Health protection and portability act
so Hippa doesn't generally apply
although we've heard that sometimes it
does some some claims that it does but
I'll tell you emphatically it does not
um so hopefully that answers a few of
the questions about how widespread the
problem is and how this aims to take a
small step to reduce lawsuits reduce
ambiguity and protect the kids and the
teachers equally
representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
you did cite um a tremendous amount of
incidents happening in marac and
throughout the state so is there an
implication that when a video is there
those incidences will be reduced thus
implying that there's abuse going
on and the reason why I ask that is
because I'm wondering if the real issue
isn't that of professional training so
that the staff knows how to manage these
children appropriately because just
having a video and seeing what goes on
doesn't solve the underlining problem so
either there is deliberate abuse going
on and we want to catch these
perpetrators or we are acknowledging
that staff is woefully unprepared to
deal with these children that's an
excellent question in a word no uh the
best use the best training tool you have
is video think about how every sports
team gets better they measure what they
want to improve they observe what they
want to improve and the first thing you
do after game Days review the game f
game film to prepare for the next game
right it everybody knows that video is
an excellent teaching tool for one so in
a in a word though answer a question do
I expect that the incidents of
restraints and seclusion will
dramatically drop not necessarily I
think there's a number of issues uh
mainstreaming of mainstreaming of kids
creation of ips there's a whole host of
issues this is a small step to increase
transparency and to learn from the
issues and learn from the incidents that
are currently happening and hopefully
make them less and make what happened
more clear to all parties to the
superintendent to the school board to
other parents right and to the parents
of the children who are secluded and
restrained
so that's that's how I think this will
go representative long thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you for the
opportunity um I I realize how many um
seclusions there are um however uh when
I spoke to the manchesters district um
although they are still struggling with
what was passed last year we heard
testimony of uh for example I mentioned
to the attorney the uh there was a door
open five people there so the trusted ad
doubt I'm assuming must be difficult um
and I certainly respect the fact that
you believe that a film will reduce I
don't uh people that are doing uh harm
uh a film a film doesn't get them to not
do harm they lose their job that's how
they're not going to do harm um so I I I
don't believe I I I tend to lean toward
towards uh Miss
Rosenberg uh when she says that it needs
work I I believe that it does need work
and um you know that it's an emergency
only um incidents that we we're now
going to be filming um I think that
makes it more complicated for uh well I
know it makes it more complicated for
the Manchester District on on getting
that
um so I I I don't agree I see where you
agree that it's going to reduce some I
don't agree that it will reduce some I
think it'll be more complicated and I
think will bring more uh more suits in
in the reporting year uh that we looked
at the most recent complete year uh
Manchester wasn't in the top five nor
was marac uh the top five were were
different different schools that I named
previously I could go back but I won't
repeat them so uh
I mean perhaps we do disagree on whether
video is a useful tool but I think what
we can agree on you mentioned it
yourself harm we can agree that harm
reduction is a good thing and reducing
one two five 100 500 cases or at least
making it more clear what happened is a
good thing so for the sake of harm
reduction for the sake of protecting the
children and the students the students
who are the children and the parents and
the teachers everybody knows what
happened why not be transparent the
state just issued $9.8 million of Grants
to help fund this uh representative as
as I was going all through this and the
question of vindication came up my mind
went to Vindication of teachers I have
Educators in my big family and sometimes
they get accused of harming Little Billy
when they were trying to calm him down
or force him not to hit other others and
I would think that any good teacher who
does the best he or she can which in an
emergency is the best one can do at the
time might welcome being videoed to
demonstrate this kid was wild and I was
trying to prevent gross harm to others
and so therefore this is what I did and
when the kid said no you didn't look at
the tape it was one of the first thank
you Mr chairman for those comments it
was one of the first cas is that when we
started investigating we I mean some of
the other Representatives representative
Mooney who was an attorney and I uh met
with some other other people outside of
the initial constituent group as we were
doing research to find out where to
place this in statute how to couple it
with the existing statute and what was
passed last session one of the first
stories we got was thank goodness we had
video because the student told his
parents that he had been jostled around
or thrown into I think it was thrown
into a wall uh and they reviewed the
hallway videotape in this case it was
hallway videotape and thank God they had
it those teachers were immediately
exonerated there was no lawsuit and they
most certainly would have been in my if
I were that parent and firmly believed
that my kid had been assaulted I
probably would have thought about a
legal action but that immediately
squashed it they looked at it and the
child have been LED peacefully down the
hall and I'm going to ask the members of
the committee who are thinking of asking
questions please limit questions to
specific technical things where we need
clarification otherwise we're going to
have a hearing and we're not supposed to
representative pinho thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative I was
just wondering if you'd deop to the idea
of interim study and the reason why I
asked that is because um maren Tracy uh
who did testify one of the marac parents
who came forth I was looking at an email
exchange that she had with some of our
committee members and she took the uh
current bill as proposed and side by
side she offered uh suggested amendments
which in my opinion enhanced the bill I
mean personally I want the parents to
know that we hear their
concerns just don't think that this
particular Bill addresses it so I'm
wondering if we can work to improve it
and interim study might be the best way
to go so thank you for the suggestion um
Moran Tracy Mrs Tracy is is behind us
here and I think she looks like she has
another constituent with her too I'm not
sure um
so I I did take a look at those
suggestions those were suggestions that
she put together by rewatching some of
the testimony is my understanding and
she can speak for herself um but the
Bill's ready to go as an initial step a
as it is I mean the nice thing about our
rsas is they're constantly in interim
study every RSA is in constant scrutiny
review that's what we do here right last
year we passed two bills on this same
subject we could have inter studied
those until we could find a way to put
them both together or put them together
with this issue I'd say let's take this
step
now and sure continue to study it the
chairman may wish to form an ad hoc
committee and continue to study and see
how it could even be expanded the one
opposition from Karen Rosenberg she said
it didn't go far enough she wants
cameras in every classroom and we've
heard that uh from a few people you know
let's put them in every single special
classroom let's get back to segregating
those students with IEPs or the special
needs students um those are all issues
for discussion but for now this is a
limited initial step so I think for what
it is on the face of it it's very well
thought out in terms of its positioning
there was a lot of discussion with legal
experts and um and seus how this would
fit in their policy uh is it workable um
and then $9.8 million in funding showed
up not all for surveillance and some of
its access control and other things but
uh but huge number of it is it's like
three 400 schools that got these fully
funded grants without objection I would
like to call the question because if the
motion on the floor fails we can have
another motion I'm not asking you to
vote against my motion but I'm just
saying this is how it works thank you so
much just a clarification yeah go ahead
I may yeah please uh the 9.8 million is
not for um restraint and seclusion
surveillance correct it's for
surveillance um so it's not for it's not
for restraint and seclusion I wanted to
be clear on that it it wasn't meant for
restraint and seclusion no it's meant
for surveillance but surveillance audio
visual surveillance can absolutely
include those seclusion rooms so in just
in just to clarify so there's
no difficulty um not all 9.8 million was
designated specifically for surveillance
programs it's about 50/50 as I went
through the four-page list um and
Manchester is not on it by the way um I
don't know why they didn't apply for
some of those grants um you did you did
just didn't get them so you maybe weight
listed okay so some it's about 5050 like
it'll be 80 80,000 or 50,000 for
surveillance and then another 50,000 for
Access Control you know key card systems
thing so it it's split up um it's
there's definitely some question of
whether you could use either money to
cover access Andor surveillance of a
seclusion room I I certainly think you
could but um anyhow but that the money
is specifically designated for
surveillance and access control uh and I
think there was one other type of
electronic records maybe or something
pie
it is this specifically a clarification
question because I would like to move on
this as soon as I can all right
representative
eimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um you
refer in uh section two as soon as
practical pursuant to RSA
18968 each use of
seclusion if I go to um RSA
18968 it specifically States
um no school shall inst install remote
surveillance
software on a school supplied Computing
device so how are we going to be keeping
these records uh so the Computing device
in my interpretation is is is different
right it's surveillance it's like
monitoring what websites you're going to
and things like that that's how I would
understand
that uh I mean that's how I read it a
school supplied Computing device right
surveillance software it's bigger than
just putting cameras on
kids representative um Nelson thank you
Mr chairman um I also reluctantly said
yes um I agree with um representative
Greg I agree with representative Patrina
representative long I would like us to
take a look at if this is a training and
accountability issue I think that it
would be helpful for us to um reach out
to um
people who are experts in this
field
um to get a better idea of how we can
help these kids thank
you before I call on anybody else would
somebody who is much more learned in
these things Define for us how an
interim study actually
works while why the chair recognizes
Wednesday Adams could you come up and
tell us uh how the interim study process
works yes of course so um folks will
plan to get together usually around
October um and then the committee can
meet as many times as they need to and I
believe I believe that the um the
deadline is the end of October November
1 I believe is is the the deadline um
but it's noticed in the calendar it's a
meeting of the committee correct and you
produce a statement of your findings and
regardless of the outcome because it
will be a new
bium you can recommend for further
legislation if you wish however
regardless of the recommendation anyone
is fre to do whatever they like in the
upcoming session but I do find these to
be helpful when these bills come up
later again because you can look at the
verbage and what was done in the um the
statement thank
you please for
um Miss Dyer
yes
well thank you uh because uh next year
will be uh a new year and possibly some
people will not be coming back isn't it
true that um legislation can be
introduced in December and if we uh
spoke with the current
um uh sponsors of the bill we may be
able to introduce legislation that uh
information comes out of the interim
study thank
you representative did you wish to speak
patrino I just wanted to make thank you
Mr chairman I wanted to make one final
point in the uh email exchanges that we
had with some of the folks um who
weren't happy with this legisl as
proposed um it was mentioned that the
state of Maine recently had a similar U
situation and a bill was passed which
they felt was Superior to what was
proposed um they mentioned that uh
experts in child uh care uh were
consulted in drafting that legislation
they saw the main uh now law to be
superior and I for one would like to
take a look and see what Maine did and
they may it may they may actually uh
answer some of our questions this could
be a wonderful project for a committee
researcher yes representative ball I
hear
the no thank you chairman pearon doing
and thank you my representative next to
me patrino for bringing that up about
the main law I would be very interested
in also finding out what is in that um
in that law that makes it Superior my
hope is that it may include cameras that
monitor all the classrooms within the
classroom within any special programs
and within any any um places where the
children calm down areas wherever they
go for that um and my reason for really
wanting that as opposed to just
individual cameras on teachers or
something is again I go back to that
antecedent and I would just like to say
that when these things happen in the
general education in classroom there is
a negative impact on the other students
in the classroom who witness the
behaviors those children can end up
being left emotionally scarred
themselves from seeing how a child um
may be acting out or how um they are
dealt with by the teacher um this goes
beyond just the one student that one
special education student it impacts
every student who is within the vicinity
of the incident thank you if I know that
we are concerned for the children
children and if I know that we are
advocating for the children would I not
ask somebody from the office of the
child advocate to come on up and say
something how is that
huh I actually just wanted to offer a
resource um to what representative
petrigno said there is an organization
based in Maine called lives in the
balance say it again lives in the
balance Dr Ross Green who is an expert
specifically in school restraint and
seclusion as well as offers an alternate
type of training we work closely with
him we're actually planning on screening
his movie in the fall and doing a panel
with his organization um they were
instrumental in passing that main law so
I'm happy to connect whoever wants to
with that organization Ben Johnson is
their legislative person's name I think
he's actually sent me a copy of that
bill um but they would be a really great
resource for your interim study group
since uh we're
called children and family law could we
come to the showing we would absolutely
plan to invite all of you and perhaps
even have someone speak on the panel
Nami hopefully will be on the panel um
but we all in our office watched that
movie in the spring and had no last fall
maybe um it's called the kids we lose
it's a phenomenal documentary about this
very issue of of child restraints in
schools would there be popcorn I will
make sure there is thank
you wow thank you okay
um seeing no further hands the Bild
before us is 1269 relative to the use of
child restraints in school the motion is
interm study move by representative
patrino and seconded by representative
Greg with the clerk please call the role
chairman Pearson yes representative long
yes representative ton yes
representative bford yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative Jaris Sullivan yes
representative L yes representative
patrino will vote Yes representative
Perez is absent representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons is absent
representative Raymond yes motion
carries 14 to Z any objection to
consent since it's an in I I would not
think they would say anything I know
it's got a fiscal note but since the
bill that actually passed is to study I
wouldn't see no objection so we can ask
for yet and they can always say no and
would you write the um the blur please
there's no need for a negative because
we all voted for
it this ends the executive session on
House Bill
1269 let's see what is
next okay um Mr chairman are we going to
put 1013 on
consent it's already
onent didn't any objection to 1013 of
blessed memory going on consent seeing
none it's on consent thank you thank you
Mr
chairman uh would you like to go next
representative D simony on
1192 relative to contempt action in
domestic relations matters your bill Mr
chairman yes I handed you um an
amendment that I would like to introduce
on um House Bill
1192 and would you like to move that
amendment I I do I were they passed
around no not
yet well I would move it as soon as I
get a copy of it well I mean they can
always say
no is this a replace
all um Amendment kind of there you go uh
it does not replace all because the
effective dat is
still correct okay no it isn't it's
section four
of only it it replaces section4 I would
like to
move
Amendment 20
24-9
4H um we felt that is moved by represent
sentive D Simone is there a second on
the
amendment I will second it so we can now
discuss it thank you Mr chairman I'll
give everybody a chance to read it uh
and absorb it what it does is uh after
lengthy discussions with
um the office of legislative Services um
Jennifer who is a retired judge really
wow um we felt that um this
amendment is integral to the contempt
order uh she felt that the entire bill
as do
um Mr Marquel and I who authored the
bill uh it's very serious a very serious
situation in divorce proceedings where
people are in domestic relations are
constantly in contempt and there's very
little going on in the courts that the
judges
have guidance from the legislature and
this Pro provides that so uh I I'd
really like to have this
amendment um accepted and uh present the
bill uh on the calendar as amended
any discussion or questions to
representative D Simone representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh representative dmon for taking my
question so having skimmed this fairly
quickly um can you correct me if I'm
wrong it looks to me like the big change
is that it it it makes it so the
attorney's fees shall be awarded the
judge won't have the option on that but
the rest of it is still up to judges
discretion um regarding incarceration
fines
Etc correct
okay thank
you anyone
else the vote is on the amendment
2024-25 House Bill
1192 FN with the motion to accept the
amendment by representative D Simone and
the second by the chair would the clerk
please call the role chairman Pearson
yes representative long yes
representative
disimon yes representative bfid
Nelson representative Nelson of the oh
okay uh rep representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Perez is absent representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons is absent
representative Raymond no okay the vote
is 12 to
one the chair will enter Ain a motion on
the bill as
amended
representative to
motion
OTP and is there a
seconds representative ball would like
to Second
it any further
discussion
representative
Bickford was it uh Jennifer Sergeant's
idea to take away discretion from the
judge on the
uh attorney
fees was it shall reward reasonable yeah
attorney fees to the prevailing
body doesn't really take the discretion
away it just gives them the opportunity
to specifically say yes we
shall says shall award reasonable
cost see under the section in which the
party alleges the court finds that a
party is in contempt or of court and has
failed without just cause to obey an
order of decree the court shall award
reasonable cause and trity fees which is
quite a change in what I think that's
probably what representative Raymond was
referring to as a loss of discretion
there
well there has to
be some
teeth to the
punishment of somebody who is being held
in
contempt well it's a matter of and
that's why it's a matter of the judge's
discretion is what's missing is taken
away way here it's not a matter of
punishing the punishment is
there I just wanted with where the idea
came from to take away the discretion
from the judge we didn't see that as
taking discretion away we gave it we see
it as giving um the judge the
extra availability uh the judge can
always make a rule against that or a
portion thereof they shall award
something it does say something it says
attorney fees shall award yeah but the
fudge factor is the word reasonable
reasonable that gives It Wide Open from
for what the judge deems to be
reasonable which could be you know yeah
it just generally you see it as May to
reasonable and there are reasons for
doing one way or the other wayse shall
do reasonable um which means they could
award $5 they could award the entire
amount so we're not taking full
discretion away $5 would be
challengeable as a attorney fee I I get
that I'm
just representative patrino thank you Mr
chairman I'm just wondering if
incarceration of a parent is in the best
interest of the
child I just wanted some thoughts on
that matter it just seems kind of
excessive in my
it depends upon whether the contempt
yeah
situation warrants incarceration if you
have a domestic violence situation and
the parent
is uh in contempt of that DV
order it these issues are never in the
best interest of the child but we have
to keep the children saved and if this
is a domestic violence order which a
contempt order would warrant
incarceration then it unfortunately is
in the best interest of the children and
the other
parent follow up uh thank you I hear
what you're saying but
again the way I'm looking at this this
would apply to any violation of the um
say the the parenting plan and it could
be something something rather simple
um and again I see incarceration there
and it just seems to be like something
that would be permitted in all
circumstances regardless of how severe
it would be and um I don't know I just
feel uncomfortable with that there I
mean clearly incarceration is
appropriate if there's domestic violence
but in other matters not so and again
knowing that your your father or your
mother's being taken away to jail
because they couldn't get along with the
other par for whatever reason to me it
would be very traumatic on on the child
that's just my thoughts well I think in
that case the it would be the judge's
discretion I don't see a judge putting
somebody in jail just because they don't
get along
with their ex uh it would have to be a
jailable
offense I I don't see a judge reading
this as the sentence stopping at the
word
incarceration I see it starting with
included but not limited to and
continuing on with fines and
reimbursements I don't see any judge
just seeing the word incarceration one
size fits all I think it's the sharpest
tool in the toolbox almost never to be
used and in the example given probably
should be and would be in the interest
of the
child anyone else representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
elaborate on that a little bit and I um
understand where representative Petrino
was coming from I personally um had been
involved in a situation where the
children were um
the one of the parents was
intentionally um kidnapping the children
um and that happened several times and
the judge actually
um told that parent that if they if they
took the
children again um away from the other
parent during that parents parenting
time and
disappeared without permission for
taking them out of state that that
parent would be incarcerated and I think
sometimes that is used as a deterrent I
think that is not in the best interest
of the children to be kidnapped away
from their other parents so that was
just something else I wanted to add to
that thank
you representative ball thank you
chairman Pearson and thank you
representative Nelson I agree with you
um this um Amendment does go on to say
that it would have to be a history of
non-compliance so it wouldn't just be
this person did something once and maybe
it wasn't so bad then they're not going
to um be subject to an incarceration but
if they're seeing a history of every
time the parent gets the child they're
taking the child out of state or
somewhere else or not returning the
child then they are clearly
demonstrating a total disregard not just
for the par parenting plan but a
disregard to New Hampshire
law thank
you representative D Simon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you all for your
comments because that is the exact
intent of the
bill we hear testimony
constantly from
parents ex spouses about this type of
action something has to be done to Cease
the action of these people who feel well
there's no consequences in a court of
law so I'm just not going to follow what
the judge tells me to do there's no
consequence there's no severe
consequence so what's the big deal I
just will do was I please and that was
the intent of this bill in the first
place in the uh special committee on the
Family Division of the circuit Court's
hearings I think we had 14 hours of
testimony from the public uh this came
up again and again and
again the judge said the other person
didn't nothing
happened representative patrino thank
you Mr chairman Mr chairman I just
wanted to thank you for your comments
that clarified uh my previous question
is given me uh some uh pause uh to think
and possibly reconsider not unless uh
other um points are U are brought forth
otherwise thank you sir but thank you I
appreciate
it representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman wasn't this bill introduced
because um it was in case law already
and it's just a matter put it into the
statutes and does that still follow
through
now yes it's to bring it over to the um
Family statutes so that it gives more
clarity to the family court
judges but the if I may the the
amendment does not change that does
it no okay that's the answer I'm looking
for thank you
if I could yeah uh yeah I mean we are
Quasi addressing this uh we have a uh
bill on a regular calendar
Thursday uh on uh enforcement of
parenting
plants um so I I you know I I just
wanted to bring that so historically
when we put two or three bills towards
one issue we get complications like we
had in the the last pill we pass
something and don't let
it don't and we don't absorb it uh and
add more that it makes it more
complicated so could it not be the case
that should both bills pass and they're
scrutinized to see are there places
where there's contradictions when both
bills go over to the Senate they'll
figure that out yeah that could happen
but I mean I I I know when I a lot of
salad something's supposed to happen and
it doesn't
always so the the point of this bill is
actually using the word
contemp
right this is actually putting make a
referral contempt in that statute so
this bill will actually give more teeth
to the bill that's on the calendar for
Thursday
the parenting plan bill doesn't discuss
contemp is what I'm trying to say
representative
Bickford thank you if I may
you you said it gives more teeth and I
don't see if it's following case law all
we're doing is transferring from case
law into the statute books which means
it doesn't give it more teeth it's just
more available more
visible so okay so we'll use that
instead is that correct okay yeah okay I
am on in the process of
examining um a couple of items in the
rule of evidence Rules of Evidence which
as you know I've read four times and in
one of the particular cases or rules the
footnotes simply give case law some of
which is mutually contradictory and all
of it taken together together is
insufficient and yet none of the people
working with me realized until we have
been doing this job for quite some time
that tucked away somewhere in the laws
is the answer to the question on that
rule
and therefore people who quickly go to
the rules of evidence and go to that
section don't know that hence the
problem and I mean I felt so good
because I'm not a lawyer although
they're trying to get me to become one
but all these wonderful lawyers didn't
see this either and somebody finally
spotted it and we all looked at each
other and uh said uh the names of these
people here will never leave this room
so there's a gag order on who all the
lawyers were that missed it but now it's
getting put going to be put into Rules
of Evidence for from the statute so I'm
defending the point that this is a good
idea even though there may be case law
it's sure good to get statute where
people
look yeah and that's my point if this is
the same as the case law there's no
reason not to just put it in the statute
books and that's a good thing oh it is I
brought two bills already following the
same thing and all those who shall
remain nameless would
agree
okay We
Ready the motion before us is House Bill
1192 FN as amended by Amendment 20
24-9
one4 moved by representative D Simone
and seconded by the chair uh excuse me
seconded by representative ball and the
clerk please call the
role jamman Pearson yes representative
long no repres representative disimon
yes representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative Sullivan no
representative LC
no representative Petrino is going to
vote Yes representative Perez is absent
representative
Greg representative Gibbons is absent
representative Raymond
no we have
925 and the motion carries 9-5
representative D Simon would you write
uh the committee report
please and uh this concludes the
executive session on House Bill
and now I open the executive session on
House Bill
1650 n and the chair is in possession of
an amendment to this
bill uh the amendment is authored by
representative post but it shall be
presented by
representative
youy that's what my little sticky
says what I do oh two
more yeah one one one pager two
sides
okay
we have enough everybody have a coffee
representative deimon um I need you to
move the amendment and it needs to be
seconded so then we can read it and
discuss it okay I would like to move um
amendment number 2024
d92 and is there a second representative
Nelson s thank you uh now let's take a
few minutes to read
it
we all set Mr chairman I'm looking
around before I forget it you've got
these documents that at your places and
so they don't get just tossed or
something they go back to the videoing
and restraining and so on so we may want
to keep these because we've got a study
session coming up in October so just
don't toss them cover looks like
this
um yeah I think we're ready
representative D Simon I did a side by
side with the original Bill and see that
the um replace all Amendment uh takes
out numbers of things and changes a few
things around would you like to walk us
through certainly Mr chairman uh if you
do this side by side you will see that
um
the first section where it talks about
unless the court order uh okay so lines
5 through nine really don't
change um in the amendment in the
amendment correct the
amendment um also does
not uh the amendment actually changes
from
in section
two the original Bill said if the court
finds the parent has without just cause
failed to abide by the terms of the
parenting schedule the court shall order
additional parenting time to the other
parent as compensation for the time lost
with the child she left that in um and
I'm not really thrilled about
that but what it does is it
it the amendment deletes uh section
lower case a which says shall be of the
same type and duration as the parenting
time that was denied or a reasonable
approximation thereof we just felt um in
discussing this with the the
representative that if parent a takes
the child for two years and parent b
gets the child back if
you don't allow the child to see parent
a for another two years that's only
hurting the child it's it's not doing
anything for the parents it's so we
asked her to take that
out
um the and we had it uh we had her just
say the court shall order the parties to
resume the parenting schedule
immediately thereafter according to the
original court ordered parenting
plan
um
so then it it does go on in addition to
reasonable attorney fees and costs under
RSA 461a the court May impose a fine of
up to of $500 for non-compliance with
the parenting plan
again um
she wanted it to say each day of
non-compliance may be considered a
separate
offense uh we had her take that
out some of the objections that came up
in the hearing it sounds like been
addressed in the um replace all
Amendment yep anyone else representative
Raymond uh thank you Mr chairman I am
really struggling with competing um
philosophies between uh DCF and
parenting plans so parenting plans are
about the best interest of the child and
that's where the judge's focus is
supposed to be DCF is about
demonstrating whether or not a child has
suffered protracted harm or impairment
as a result of abuse or neglect if we
now
tie withholding parenting time to a
finding of abuse or neglect we are
saying to the judge forget best
interests now we only want you to make
decisions based on whether or not a
child has had protracted harm and so I'm
thinking of a situation where DCF gets a
report that a parent is on drugs right
and there's a concern that the child is
not being properly supervised because of
the parents drug habit it would be very
common for a dcyf worker to go out and
make a temporary safety plan and say hey
until we determine whether or not parent
B is on drugs at this current moment we
want you to keep the kid here with you
right so let's send out the police and
let's go check it out and make sure it's
safe so parent B might lose one day of
parenting time DCF might go out and find
out that parent B either wasn't on drugs
or does routinely use drugs but not
during their parenting time therefore
it's okay under our state
law that's an unfounded
report under this now parent be who has
a drug problem but it isn't a finding of
neglect has to have compensatory
parenting time and all of this other
stuff to me that just really complicates
and confuses the issues and I can think
of dozens of other examples off the top
of my head where a dcif worker in
conjunction typically with with law
enforcement might say to a parent when
they receive a report hey can we do a
temporary safety plan it's Friday
afternoon at 3 pm we can't interview
everybody till Monday can you hold the
kids this weekend because it's in their
best interest to not be placed at risk
of harm and now I I see us ending up
with all of these court dates for
parents who are like well dcyf unfounded
it clearly there's no problem I want my
C my time back and that's not putting
the best interest of the kids first we
already passed a bill this year about
false reporting right now we're saying
reasonable reports that DCF is
reasonably making effort to keep Kids
Safe we're now going to interfere with
custody plans I just it makes me really
uncomfortable and I think it's going to
cause a huge backlog in the court system
and and I also don't think that it's
letting judges have their discretion to
say what's best for kids in these
situations representative long thank you
Mr chairman um I I do also see that and
I and I also see uh I I'm looking at
this as a the child being treated as a
pawn or a tool um to add the time to the
other parent uh for
example my ex doesn't want me signing up
my son for football I signed him up but
I have that time with him when we
practice and and play games so if I if
this was me that for whatever reason I'm
not allowing my wife I'm not sending the
child
back she would get extra time with the
child and that would be that would be
gone so I I I'm looking at this as the
disruption to the child I I get the
compensation for the parents but I'm
looking at it as the child's uh how is
the child disrupted um and and I I think
there's Avenues with which they will be
disrupted um and a $500 fine where where
does that go to a court where the finds
go does it go to the other parent that's
suffering and get me to pay my child
support when I got to pay 500 a day if I
if I'm
more anyone
else representative ball thank you
chairman
PE um when a child is kept away from
their parent it negative ly impacts the
relationship between the parent and
child so this is not just about the
parent losing time it's the child losing
time and ability to continue to build a
relationship with their parent so if in
the case that representative um Raymond
mentioned where dcyf might say well
while we investigate this we're going to
leave it with the we're going to keep
the child with the other parent for the
weekend I agree that if if nothing is
found then then make that time up the
following weekend um there's no reason
to not to deny the child I'm not talking
about denying the parent this is denying
the child their rightful time with both
parents and I think that um we should
not be focusing on what the parent is
losing but this bill focuses on what the
child is losing and that's the access to
both parents thank
you representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman further to representative um
Ball's input um you know I have had
experience being a stpp parent and also
have um from privy to other healthy
co-parenting situations and it generally
is um practice that sometimes a parent
uh will request of the other parent uh
additional time for whatever reason
going away on vacation to visit family
or what what not and um then you know
then it's it's a you know it's an
agreement that you know the other parent
gets a little more time um somewhere
else so I don't um think that that's
unreasonable to um to have here in this
amendment representative Greg I'm
concerned with the direction that we
continue to keep going in this committee
where we pass one bill and then we have
another bill that either confuses it or
competes with it we've already passed
106 through here which covers most of
this I'm not sure why we're we're having
so many bills that are so different when
they come into our committee and I I'm
just concerned about the message that
we're sending about the functionality of
our committee when we continue to do
this if you think that believe me when
the chairs
meet with 700 800 bills where people who
might or could have got together ahead
of time before they issued a series of
overlapping bills believe me we agree
with you
in every
committee and that solves nothing but
here we go representative Bickford
concerning bills they they have been
vetted um at legislative services that
each one has its own uh Merit the
trouble is that you hear one but you
haven't heard the other one yet and and
we passing them before that we do the
next one um so we can weigh in on that
now as far as this amendment goes I like
everything in it except one thing and I
would have liked to again on line 19 not
seeing shall the court shall order I
think we could work around it the way
it's written because it doesn't say it
has to be the same amount of time like I
I do like some degree of judicial
discretion Shia usually takes that away
but I think the way it continues to read
order additional par paring time to the
other parent as compensation for time
lost with the child now there are some
parents they can't make up that time
because of their jobs I have a I'm going
to call him a son-in-law that's he has
two other another relationship if it
happens to him he has to be a work so he
would have to probably turn down that
compensatory time the way this written
I'm going to say I think it's
okay that they they could say to the
judge I really can't make that up we're
going to have to to find some other way
to to do it but in the future I'd like
to see more discretion with the word
made for the judges thank you also what
some of thank you also what some of the
chairs try to do is if we see bills that
are very similar we will try to do them
on the same day but there are a number
of reasons why we can't always do that
because uh like you may remember when
Senator Whitley came over we had a
senator Becky Whitley afternoon because
she had three bill b s and rather than
having her make a special trip three
times I put all of hers together so I'm
aware of that and I try to do that with
topics but sometimes there are things
that intervene but I I I share the
frustration of too many bills and too
many overlapping bills well we we used
to do more uh side by sides uh when we
had bills like we is a difference what
does what sure so keep that in mind
thank you we'll do anyone else
representative you know repres senat of
Sullivan there's no gag oder here on you
I'm not saying you have to speak but
committee you can do anything except
make motions so okay the chair
recognizes representative Sullivan for
thinking about doing something I
actually am curious what I obviously
wasn't here for any of the testimony but
what is this goal essentially to try to
prevent people from using children as
pwns or a bad faith parent doing
something is that is that the goal and
is that a common problem that that needs
to be fixed like what I'm going I know
that this is now it's everybody here's
opinion but like we don't know what the
the original sponsor was hoping for I'm
just trying to understand the intent
here whoever wants to answer it
representative long yeah we hear the
committee that that's one of the major
issues in this committee are parents um
kids are being PL as PA so that that is
a major issue and a lot of these bills
are looking at attempts to uh decrease
that um so that's what's this about I my
opinion I don't believe it does that I
think it adds to their being used as
pawns uh but to re to uh represent a
bigford
point um it says the court shall order
additional parenting time so the Court's
going to order additional parenting time
and what you're thinking is that if if I
refuse it because I can't do it then
that's that's that will be
done or am I or do I have to take the
added parenting time it
says but I mean
I right but I'm wondering if if
there's if this can be interpreted
as the other the the parent getting
compensated can refuse it I don't know
if they can because the judge
shall shall be so you're I'm gonna say
yeah judge that order I'm not going to
accept that order yeah I don't think
that
flies you
know yes representative Bal thank you
chairman Pearson and to representative
Bickford's point I actually like the
word shall in there I think that using
the word may makes it a crapshoot it's
like well it's 50/50 we don't know which
way the judge is going to go so I'm
going to just try it let's see but the
word shall kind of puts a pause on that
to say h I might I might have to pay for
this decision of holding withholding my
children from you know just to be mean
I'm going to withhold the child um it it
doesn't say that time is going to be one
to one it just says that he shall order
the the um extra time and I'm sure that
the parent is sitting there they can
actually when this comes up can say I
don't have time or perhaps they would
just rather have an extra week um this
reminds me of military situations when a
person is deployed upon their return in
many parenting um plans upon the return
they get the child for a week even
though they've been deployed for six
months or a year they get a week
vacation like one solid week with the
child
um to make up for the time that they've
lost with their child and that's you
know it's a different situation but I I
see it as being the same that when the
child is taken it may not be a onetoone
return but there needs to be somehow
that that parent gets a little bit of
extra time um to reconnect with their
child and bond um with
them the motion before is is on the
amendment 2024
921 H to House Bill 6 19 59 FN the
amendment was moved by representative D
Simon and seconded by representative
Nelson would the clerk please call the
role on the amendment chairman Pearson
yes representative long no
representative
disimone yes representative bfid yes
representative Nelson
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes
representative Panic
yes representative Sidell yes
representative
Sullivan representative LC no
representative patrino will be voting no
representative Perez is absent
representative Greg no representative
Gibbons is absent representative Raymond
no motion passes 8 to6 with two
absent will now entertain a subsequent
motion representative D
simony and uh
second I saw representative Ball's hand
first otpa any further
discussion the motion before us is ought
to pass on House Bill 1659 FN is amended
by Amendment 202
4921 ought to pass as amended moved by
representative D Simone seconded by
representative ball the clerk please
call the
rooll chairman Pearson yes
representative long no representative
disimon yes representative bfid
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative panic
yes representative Sidell yes
representative Sullivan no
representative LC no representative
Patrina will vote no representative
Perez is absent representative
Greg representative Gibbons is absent
representative Raymond motion passes 8
to6 the motion passes as amended uh
House Bill 1659 passes
8-6 representative D Simon would you uh
C write the committee report unless
there's somebody who would like to help
the soon to be town of Atkinson tax
collector amerita with her crushing load
of committee reports yeah I could write
the majority report on that I don't
think
so oh than I'm trying to help you I'm
trying to help you with all of your
duties keeping Manchester in order you
would undertake this
task
and with
that the exec session on 1659 is
adjourned and so is this and because
you've all been so good and you've
worked so hard this committee will
reconvene when the Senate sends us
things in crossover you have next
Tuesday off that
fantastic they thought we were done with
our bills
yeah did did you know did you know that
representative Gibbons wasn't
I